hey guys Pete here the west-world hype
is close to unbearable right now so I
decided to do an episode 9 trailer
breakdown it will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened up to this
point in the show so if you aren't
caught up this video won't be for you
with that out of the way let's get into
it there is a synopsis for episode 9
floating around the internet which I'll
read first it goes like this
Dolores and Bernard reconnect with their
pasts Maeve makes a bold proposition to
Hector Teddy finds enlightenment at a
price so not a whole lot there but there
are a couple of interesting tidbits
let's break down the trailer first and
see how this stuff might fit in after
that
the trailer starts out with William
being carried and chair by two soldiers
Dolores said they were a union scouting
party when they rode up at the end of
last episode but we also know Logan was
with them so they're definitely
Confederate OHS it's like they're
presenting him to the crowd of soldiers
or presenting something to him
as to make him watch either way it
doesn't look like a good spot for him we
hear Dolores say you told me to follow
the maze that it would bring me joy but
all I found is pain and terror we see
them wrestling with her which could be
in front of William since we see him
looking terrified the last shot we get
is Dolores looking up at someone with a
combination of what looks like fear and
anger in her eyes next we see Bernard
with Maeve in the center
he asked what motivated your attack on
Clementine when she doesn't answer he
says let's jog your memory and then she
grabs his wrist
he's clearly shocked by what's happening
which means that she was probably in
analysis mode when he asked the question
she then says we've been down this road
before it cuts away at that to a
sequence that flashes out of darkness we
see Maeve holding and then shooting a
shotgun and a host standing next to
Hector getting shot in Florida office
Bernard says you broke into my mind and
we here for a dancer I built your mind
then we see him get off a gurney which
could be when he was first built it's
not clear at all but since he says I
built your mind overtop of it it could
be a flashback to that we see the scene
change from Ford's office to what looks
like the cold storage area where Ford
was drinking with Bill
here Bernards say what else have you
hidden from me we get two flashes one is
of this hallway which doesn't look
familiar to me it looks like it's from
the past and there is a body against the
wall but you can't make out who it is
even when you zoom in I have no idea
where this is other than just guessing
wildly so let me know where you guys
think it might be and who the person is
the second flashes of Teresa after we
see that it cuts to Bernard sitting with
his eyes closed and then he jumps up
suddenly we hear Angela telling the man
in black that the maze isn't meant for
you she says if you like game so much
why don't you try one of ours then we
hear the man in black say why it'd take
me two while we see the doors opening at
the white church there's a bot there's a
person there it looks like the man in
black at least as far as the Hat but
there's no way to tell for sure because
it's in silhouette then it starts to
flash there's only two episodes left and
we get a shot at Dolores running with a
gun in her hand in the next flash we see
fire in the background and what looks
like Maeve and Hector getting it on in
the last shot we see the Confederate OHS
dead on the ground with someone standing
in the middle looking at the carnage
based on the clothes it looks like Logan
to me but you can't really tell for sure
I was reading something earlier and
people seem to be torn like some are
convinced that it's William so let me
know what you guys think at first glance
I thought okay someone shot them up but
if you look closely these guys have
limbs hacked off there's bottles of
liquor laying next to them that aren't
broken so it doesn't look like there was
an explosion or anything like that it
almost looks like something that why
it's men might have done but that
wouldn't line up with the current time
frame theories so what did we find out
well I think what is most striking for
me is that Maeve gets out of the center
I mean I guess it's a no-brainer that
that would happen but that was like an
impenetrable complex before it seems
safe to say that she went there straight
away and then to have interactions with
Hector she must get out I tried to go
back through some of the old episodes to
see if I could find Ford saying we've
been down this road before to Barnard
but I couldn't find one with a quick
look but what I'm thinking is
mave could rewrite the storylines for
the other host we know that so why can't
she do it to Bernard
even if Ford uses verbal commands
there's no reason she wouldn't be able
to find out what they were I mean she
has admin access and can edit her own
code it seems like the possibilities for
what she can do inside the system would
be limitless it's not clear by any means
but it looks like she could move right
past it this is interesting because
since about the fourth episode it looked
like Arnold was going to be Ford's
biggest adversary at the end of the
season now I think Maeve could be a
bigger problem if she can control
Bernard is that what's making him
confront forward throughout the trailer
in the last episode he erased his
memories that might set them back in
their work but granted he did see the
flash of Elsie I don't know if we're
gonna see an Arnold reveal but I do know
Maeve's going to cause problems
Bernard doesn't seem to be playing the
role that Ford expects him to in what we
see in the trailer so it's likely
there's a big conflict getting ready to
happen between those two when Bernard
woke up after killing Teresa he tried to
attack Ford who could easily freeze him
Maeve could obviously upset this balance
but I just don't know if that fits into
her skate plan of course if she did set
that up that way that would distract
Ford from everything else and that would
be to her advantage the synopsis says
Maeve makes a bold proposition to Hector
which sounds like they'll team up to get
out
I find the wording strange though
because she could just tell him what to
do like she did with the other host in
the last episode I'm not sure why there
has to be a proposition or like what he
has to offer that would be so essential
and her being able to complete her plan
it says that Dolores and Bernard
reconnect with their past if we see
Bernard getting bill and we here for
talk about building his mind does this
mean we'll find out what his origin
actually is in this timeline the man in
black is actually pushing the action by
going after Wyatt so what does that have
to do with Bernard if why it's based on
Arno
could that story unlock the key to us
understanding if bernard is based off
him I'm skeptical at this point for the
simple reason that there's only two
episodes left I'm not sure everything's
gonna get sorted by the end of season 1
although I wouldn't mind it I think
we'll know more about where things are
headed before the finale it says that
Teddy you will find enlightenment for a
price this is a little vague Teddy's a
late comer to having the memories that
he's starting to have and to this point
he hasn't really taken the man in black
at his word about how things work in
this world this could be tied to the man
in black saying that he was going to
change the rules or he knows how to
change the rules but it's it's a little
vague I I don't really see what this
means
100% I mean if the price is his life
then he's going to get reset I don't
think that it's saying that he's gonna
go through the maze all of a sudden and
you know everything's gonna work out for
him so I'm a little bit cautious as to
just throw guesses out there on that one
as far as Dolores reconnecting with her
past I guess this is what I find to be
the most interesting unknown we're here
talking to Arnold or who we think is
Arnold by saying that she went to the
maze and all she found was pain and
suffering or whatever so this is
actually like I said if we get more of
that if we get more of her memories like
we saw in the last episode of the early
days and what actually went wrong that
could be the most exciting reveal only I
don't know if this is going to be one of
those series where episode 9 is where
the big thing happens and then in
episode 10 they just sort of wrap it up
or if this is going to be like a
two-part finale where episode 9 sort of
like the first half in episode tens the
second half I mean typically HBO shows
sort of have their big blowout in the
ninth episode so there could be a big
reveal as far as what's going on with
her but it's really just speculation at
this time I think what we're really
gonna see move forward is we're gonna
see Maeve put her plan into action I
think we'll see the man in black move
forward I don't think we're gonna see
him get to the end of
yet and then I think everything else is
too soon the call because we really
don't know how they're gonna structure
the last two episodes let me know in the
comments what you guys want to see what
you think's gonna happen were you
surprised to see Maeve out there with a
shotgun in her hand what do you think
about all these guys that are like
laying there with limbs cut off I mean
that that's a little bit crazy
and who is the person sitting in there
like Logan makes so much more sense to
me but let me know what you guys think
please like the video if you enjoyed it
and please subscribe to my channel to
keep up to date with all my latest
videos thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon